so hello and welcome to another episode
of biographics I'm your interim host KL
Smallwood yes that's my real name go
look it up on social media the links
below if you don't believe me and today
we're talking about Harry Thor the
original killer Playboy and this video
is based on original article by Ru
Alexander if they provided any Social
Links for us you can find them below
alongside my own let's get to
it trial of the s Cy it's a short and
snappy phrase that grabs people's
attention that's probably why the Press
had relied on it whenever dealing with a
high-profile court case to drump as much
interest as possible for a juicy story
to dominate those headlines and colum
inches hey even we here at biographics
haven't shied away from using that old
adage when describing some of the
stories we've covered which was the
trial of Rosco Fatty Arbuckle for the
murder of Virginia rape or the trial of
Dr Sam Shepard who stood accused of
killing his wife those videos were
prevented by our previous far more
aerodynamic host Simon Whistler who you
know we wish him all the best and
hopefully I'm doing good in his stad but
today we're going back even further it's
one of the first cases to ever earn the
moniker of trial of the century and to
this day is still one of the most
intriguing and shocking the 1906 murder
of renowned American architect Stanford
white at the hands of the mentally
unstable Playboy Harry Thor ostensibly
to protect the honor of his wife Fame
supermodel Evelyn Nesbit so what made
this cas so compelling one contemporary
repter listed all the quality of this
murder Scandal that grip the nation you
see it had in it wealth degeneracy Rich
old waer delectable young chorus girls
and Adolescent artists models behind the
scenes of theom with the underworld and
the Great White way the abnormal
pastimes and weird orgies of overly
aesthetic artists and jaded DEET this is
the story of a love triangle that ended
in Murder became from page news all over
the country as America waited to find
out with baited breath what fate would
Beall Harry Thor the killer
Playboy hurry Kendall Thor was born
February 12th 1871 in alany City
Pennsylvania today a part of Pittsburgh
to William Thor senior and his second
wife Mary CET Copley to say that Harry
was born with a diamond stuttered Silver
Spoon in his mouth would still be an
understatement his father was a railroad
magnate estimated to be among the 100
richest people in America at the time
unsurprisingly young Harry lacked
nothing in his life even though from
childhood he exhibited paranoid behavior
and was prone to outbursts of violence
at no point did anybody ever really try
to do anything to correct his conduct
punish his actions or even try and get
him professional help since it was
probable that he struggled with some
kind of mental illness instead if Harry
got into trouble at school and got
expelled his father would simply move
him to another fancy private school yeah
the Patrick solution from SpongeBob de
like take the problem move it somewhere
else from a young age Harry was taught
that his money and social status placed
him above of the rules of society which
were used to govern was mere mortals
acting the way he did Harry never really
did well in school but this mad little
when it was time for college his father
made sure that he got accepted into the
University of Pittsburgh to study law
there was little studying to be had
though and soonly enough Harry would
have even less incentive to do so in
1889 William Thor died leaving behind a
giant trust fund for Harry and a
generous yearly allowance and by
generous we mean more money than most
mere mortals could spend in several
lifetimes Harry Thor was now a very very
rich man and free to indulge in his
every wi and not that his father was
ever a drill sergeant or anything when
it came to raising him but his mother
was even more nonchalant about his
behavior he was her first child so he
was the apple of her eye and throughout
the rest of her life she would always be
more concerned with protecting her son
from the consequences of his actions
rather than trying to get into rain in
his ways and stop being a up until this
point Harry wanted to attend the
University of Pittsburg because it meant
you could go home to his palacial estate
instead of living in a cramp dormatory
now however finding SU living
arrangements was no longer a concern so
he used his new found wealth to transfer
to Harvard and this was only done for
bragging rights and so that Thor could
say he attended the prestigious Harvard
University just like before he had no
interest in any of the scholarly
Pursuits that college had to offer once
when asked what he studied at Harvard
Thor jokingly replied poker which had
been complimented by bouts of all night
drinking bingers and attending [__]
fights as well as a string of quick and
sultry romances the all night drinking
sounds like my nights at College none of
the other stuff why is he would reach
[__] fights who wants to see a chicken
tear another chicken apart instead of
you go an all night drinking binge and
then you tear the chicken apart as part
of the KFC money might have gotten Thor
through the door of Harvard but it
didn't keep him there it would seem that
he went a step too far one night when he
chased a cup driver armed with a shotgun
Thor's defense was that the weapon was
unloaded but the University president
probably had to deal with one too many
spoiled Bratz that day and expelled him
poor Harry was thrown out onto the
streets but then he remembered oh I'm A
Millionaire and I can do whatever the
hell I want and he cheered up a little
bit after he was done with his quote
unquote education he spent his time
between alony and New York City with
frequent trips to Europe where he would
let loose a little and unwind after all
those stressful months of doing nothing
back at home he was already starting to
develop a reputation his parties and his
ancts were becoming well known both in
New York and in Europe in the Press
there was even a popular new word used
to describe the lifestyle of someone
like Harry Thor that's of a
Playboy
hry Thor might be the guy whose name is
in the title of this video but he only
makes up one3 our lethal love triangle
so let's move on to his other two bed
fellows first up is Evelyn Nesbit a
woman once to up the most beautiful
artist model in the world and regarded
by some as the world's first true superm
model with that kind of cl's Fame it's
no surprise really that men were willing
to quite literally kill for her but
we're get ahead of ourselves Florence
Evelyn Nesbit was born on Christmas Day
oh in 1884 in a small community just
outside of Pittsburgh Pennsylvania the
family moved to the city a few years
later where Evelyn's father Winfield
Scott Nesbit worked as a lawyer who was
struggling to make ends meat things got
significantly worse when Winfield Scott
passed away leaving his family in debt
without a source of secure income it was
a desperate time for the nbits but
fortunately for them Evelyn grew into a
stunning Beauty from a young age she was
first asked to pose for a portrate by an
artist from Philadelphia when she was
only 13 years old afterwards she posed
for a photographer and her pictures made
it into art magazines that garnered a
lot of attention it wasn't long before
she was one of the most indiand models
in Philadelphia and the money she was
earning was enough to support her young
family seeing this Evelyn's mother
realized that this could not only be a
viable but highly lucrative career for
her daughter so in 1900 the two packed
their bags and moved to New York City in
the hopes they would strike it big and
indeed they did word of Evelyn's
transcendental Beauty had already
reached the city and it wasn't long
until the 15-year-old model was sought
out by some of the biggest artists in
the country James Beckwith was the first
painter in New York City to take young
Evelyn under his wing and introduced her
to many prominent names in the art world
she posed as a Gibson girl for Charles
dar's Gibson drawings women the Eternal
question and George Gray Bernard
sculpture maidenhood parenthesis
innocence not to mention countless
magazines such as Harpers bizar and
Vanity Fair but it was in Gibson's
Studio that Evelyn met the third and
final piece about pzzle a man by the
name of Stanford white 30 years her
senior U Stanford white was one of the
biggest Hot Shots in the architectural
World by the time he met Evelyn he had
made his name and his fortune by mainly
designing lavis mansions for the rich
and the famous but he also had several
notable landmarks to his credit such as
the Washington Square arch in Manhattan
Tiffany's jewelry store and the second
incarnation of Madison Square Garden
white was also the kind of man who got
what he wanted and once he set his eyes
on Evelyn he decided he wanted her at
that point the young model was looking
to expand her Horizons and join the
world of theater getting a part in one
of the most popular Broadway shows of
the early 20th century a musical comedy
titled floradora the play featured a
line of beautiful chorus girls of which
Evelyn was now a part collectively known
as the floradora girls this also meant
that Stanford white could see Evelyn
whenever he wanted to at first he played
the role of a benevolent benefactor he
started out with some compliments then
he bought Evelyn a few gifts and before
you know it he was putting her up in a
luxurious apartment and giving her an
allowance of course all of this was
simply the Prelude to what white was
really after one night Evelyn's mother
was away in Pittsburgh visiting
relatives and it was just the two of
them and white made his move again I
reiterate e what exactly happened that
night depends on whose account you
believe but at best the architect got a
16-year-old girl drunk and took
advantage of her at worst he drugged and
raped her she was 16 it was rape what an
Evelyn despite her beauty and success
from an early age was still naive and
inexperienced the influence and control
that white had exerted over her was too
strong so even after what happened that
night the two began an affair now
it's not Affair it's it's child abuse
the relationship if we can call it that
no we can't lasted for about a year
before the architech grew Bor of the
chorus girl this was standard practice
for Stanford white so let me just
rephrase that this was standard practice
for known Stanford white Evelyn Nesbit
was not the first girl to receive the
treatment nor would she be the last his
reputation as a predator who targeted
young women was well known in New York's
high society as evidence by none other
than Mark Twain who briefly wrote about
the murder trial in it autobiography
here is what the novelist had to say
about Stanford white the witness charges
the middle-age architect with eagerly
and diligently and ravenously and
remorselessly hunting young girls to
their destruction these facts have been
well known in New York for many years
but they've never been openly proclaimed
until now on the witness stand in the
hearing of a courtroom crowded with men
the girl told in the minutest detail the
history of White's pursuit of her even
down to the particulars of his atrocious
Victory a victory whose particulars
might as well be said to be on principal
New York City has known for years that
the highly educated and elaborately
accomplished Stanford white was a
Shameless and pitiless wild beast
disguised as a human being and few if
any have doubted that he ought to have
been butchered Long Ago by some kindly
friend of the human
race during one of Stanford White's
famous parties Evelyn made the
acquaintance of 21-year-old John
barimore part of the illustrious
Barrymore acting family and the two
became smitten with one another although
John barimore would go on to achieve
great Fame in his career this version of
him however was a young struggling
artist who mainly did illustrations for
newspapers and the like Evelyn's mother
did not approve of their budding romance
so when Barry Mo proposed marriage she
sent her daughter away to a boarding
school in New Jersey when she was still
performing on Broadway Evelyn followed
up her successful stint in Florida with
a part in the Wild Rose where she had a
more prominent wrong instead of Simply
being a chorus girl once again she
dazzled her adoring public and among the
audience left Smith WR by a beauty was
none other than the villain of today's
piece Harry Thor at first Harry tried to
win Evelyn over under the guise of Mr
Monroe and sent her lots of expensive
flowers after each performance of The
Wild Rose often accompanied by a $20 or
even $50 bill what a romantic this alone
was hardly enough to make Evelyn Swoon
after all she had plenty of rich men
vying for her affection she was not
impressed and had most of the gifts sent
back eventually Thor tried scheduling a
lunch date with the actress through a
common acquaintance and as it happened
he picks the perfect time Evelyn was
feeling pretty down about the whole
having to return to boarding school and
being abused thing so she thought she
might as well meet up with the
mysterious and friendly Mr Monroe at the
very least it might make for an
intriguing interaction when the two were
face to face the Playboy dropped the
fake name and facade announced himself
proudly as Harry Thor of Pittsburgh his
favorite way of introducing himself but
this left the actress more beused than
impressed the lunch did not go
particularly well and Evelyn felt relief
when Thor Departed he was not the kind
of man to give up so easily he continued
his dogged pursuit of her partly out of
passion but also out of a desire to harm
and humiliate Stanford white you see
when and how exactly the animosity
between the two men started we cannot
say we can tell you that Harry Thor loed
the architect before he'd ever heard of
Evelyn Nesbit this may have all begun
with a single bad interaction at a party
but in Thor's paranoid mind he soon
became convinced that Stanford White had
made it his mission to turn him into a
social Riya uses many connections to
deny Thor entry into the most
prestigious clubs in New York such as
the Metropolitan the nicab boka and the
Players Club it couldn't be that he was
just a paranoid anyway the Playboy
millionaire kept trying to woo Evelyn
although he had more success winning
over the girl's mother than Evelyn
herself then an opportunity presented
itself for Thor to show his dedication
towards the young actress Evelyn felt
ill with the pendes situs being there
while she was recuperating she stayed in
a sanatorium in New York City and and as
you would expect both white and th
visited her often to Lavish her with
gifts and attention however by the time
she returned home white was starting to
get bored with her and was ready to move
on to the next show girl Harry pounced
on this moment and convinced Evelyn's
mother to let him take her daughter on
an extended trip to Europe in May 1903
to Aid in her recovery I I guess just
1903 was just a different just let your
child go with a mysterious millionaire
stranger time at first he was the
perfect gentleman even as Evelyn
continuously rebuffed his offers of
marri and romance then things changed
when he finally got to recount how
Stanford white took advantage of her
outwardly he was caring and consoling
towards Evelyn he said all the right
things but there was a definite change
in his demeanor he became colder and
started making snide remarks not only
towards white but also towards Evelyn
while visiting Dom the birthplace of
jeon of Arc Thor wrote in the guest book
that she would not have been a virgin if
Stanford White had been
around um Pro tip for any women watching
if guys start talking like this leave
just go go it's not worth it just throw
the whole man out while in Austria
Hungary Thor rented out Casten Stein
castle where the couple stayed for a few
weeks in that remote edifice where the
two were isolated and alone except for a
few servants who stayed at the opposite
end of the castle Evelyn saw for the
first time the true Harry thorw one
night he burst into a room naked he
began tearing at a night gown and
whipping her violently with a riding
crop the harder she fought the harder he
hit her till the body was full of long
bloody lacerations he then proceeded to
assault her the same way as white had
done years earlier the attack stopped as
suddenly as it began afterwards Thor got
up calmly left the room and locked the
door behind him the next day he acted as
if nothing had happened and the European
tour continued it wasn't until October
that Evelyn arrived back in New York
City but Thor continued his Pursuit the
undeterred and shockingly it worked
perhaps Evelyn felt trapped between two
violent domineering men and was
obviously getting no help from her
mother like where was she in all of this
and thought that she had no choice but
to choose one of them the lesser of two
evils as it were perhaps she thought
that as words spread around town that
she was Stanford White's mistress her
chance of finding a respectable and
loving husband would go down
dramatically or perhaps she actually
believed Thor when he said that he was a
changed man and was run over by his
continuous gestures of generosity and
affection whatever the case after two
years of courtship as it's uh generously
put in the original article Evelyn
agreed to Marry Harry Thor the couple
got hitched on April 4th 1905 and the
newspapers proclaimed Evelyn ASB to be
the Mistress of
Millions
before their wedding Thor had promised
Evelyn that he would behave like a
Benedictine monk from then on he even
had the audacity to tell her that he
forgave her for the relationship with
white you know the relationship where
she was raped the couple moved to the
family mansion in Pittsburgh where Thor
seemingly did adopt a calmer more
approachable human demeanor likely
because he was around his own mother one
thing that did not change however was
his intense hatred of Stanford white and
he took away moral campaigns trying to
expose him as the true blackard that he
was Evelyn meanwhile was bored and
largely resigned herself to the quite
depressing existence she found herself
in she spent most of her days C to
inside with her mother-in-law and her
friends she barely saw anyone her own
age or received any social invitations
after about a year of marriage Thor
decided to take Evelyn on another trip
to Europe with a short stop in New York
City to enjoy a bit of high society
while in the city the couple decided to
catch a play and on June 25th 1906 it
was the opening night for Mel champagne
playing on the rooftop theater of
Madison Square Garden Thor bought
tickets and they went to see the play
during the show guess who showed up it
was none other than Stanford white at
his own private table since remember he
did design the building as the finale of
the play was approaching on stage a
singer was belting out I could love a
million girls when the entire audience
was startled by three gunshots they
looked around and saw Harry Thor pistol
in hand standing over White's now dead
body his face almost unrecognizable
covered in blood and gunpowder at that
point Harry shouted something nobody
paid close attention to the exact
wording of but it was something to the
effects of I did it because he ruined my
wife again laid it run then when he was
taken into custody he simply reiterated
that white had gotten what he deserved
Harry Thor was arrested charged with
first-degree murder and imprisoned in
the Manhattan Detention complex aka the
tombs however the preferential treatment
Thor received in prison still made his
life better than 99% of the country he
slept in a big brass bed instead of a
regular jail cart was allowed to wear
his tail of Suits there of a prisoner's
uniform received catered meals from
fancy restaurants and even had daily
allowances of wine and champagne brought
to him unsurprisingly he was in an
almost constantly happy mood not just
due to his living conditions but also
because he was convinced the world would
see him as a hero for ridding it of a
scoundrel like Stanford white the trial
of the century began on January 25th
1907 the defense wanted to declare Harry
Thor insane but he was not having any of
that neither was his mother who was
fiercely protective of her family's
reputation her son had murdered someone
in front of aund witnesses instead
mother Thor hired a new legal team led
by Deli Delmas and told them to pursue a
defense of temporary insanity or a
brainstorm as they referred to it back
then in fact delass even introduced a
new term to explain Thor's sudden and
unexpected bout of violence dementia
Americana he argued that there are
certain things that are sacred to the
American man the honor of his wife being
Chief among them so it was
understandable even justifiable that
Thor temporarily lost control of his
sensors in order to avenge the honor of
his wife and here's the thing some jury
members actually bought this the first
trial deadlocked 7 to5 in favor of
guilty the second trial began in January
1908 and lasted only a month this time
Thor's team went after the insanity
defense without any bells and whistles
and it worked Harry Thor was found not
guilty by reason of insanity and was
committed to a state hospital with a
criminally insane obviously his team
went immediately to security release but
this didn't work so in 1913 they just
busted him out they colluded with a
keeper to get Thor out of the building
and transport him over the border to
Canada where another team of high pric
lawyers had already secured the rights
to fight any extradition attempts it
wasn't until 1915 that he was extradited
to New York when he was charged with
conspiracy to escape conspiracy he was
in Canada like I get it like you know
the the the the gears of the legal
system move slowly but they do grind
finely but conspiracy to escape when
he's already escaped seems like you know
a bit lacking in regards to like you
know the severity of what you Tred to
accuse the person of two trials later
and on July 16th 1915 Harry Thor was
declared not only legally sane but also
a free man since technically he couldn't
be tried again for the same murder he'd
already stood trial for which I didn't
think was a I didn't think Double
Jeopardy was a real thing but here we
are the district's attorney rightfully
decried this decision as a gross
miscarriage of Justice made possible
only thanks to Thor's vast fortune and
his mother's own mations just rich
people don't go to jail the same way do
they and did Thor learn a lesson no once
he was free he divorced Evelyn and went
to California where he once again
indulged in bouts of sadism less than a
year later he was charged with beating
and whipping a 19-year-old boy called
Fred Gump Thor fled from the police and
when they finally caught with him in
Philadelphia he tried to commit suicide
by slashing his own throat he survived
but this was enough to get him declared
insane again and sent to an asylum again
no Escape this time and Thor spent seven
years in there before being released
after that point he stayed away from the
headlines if he continued his streak of
violence and cruelty he managed to do it
without anyone really finding out and he
died on February 12th 1947 he was 76
years old for anyone curious about
Evelyn's fate uh she did have a child
with Thor or at least she claimed
because Thor dis sell the child and
claimed it wasn't his after their
divorce she was forced to earn an income
and return to the stage appearing in a
couple of silent films before finding
steady and long career in v will and
cabaret shows she died on January 17th
1967 she was 82 years old so thank you
for tuning into this episode of
biographics as not at the start I've
been your interim host Kyle Smallwood
yes it's my real name you find links in
my socials Below in addition to links to
my own channel where I have a decidedly
more LAX and less professional approach
than I do here if you can believe it as
mentioned this video is based on
original article by Ru Alexander find
Links of their stuff below it also link
below will be like you know the sources
use the original article and just you
know our sister channels Geographics and
top 10s on which I'm also the interim
host right you know we appreciate
everyone for watching this video if you
like the video leave a like if you have
anything to say about it please leave a
comment and specifically I'd like to
request any feedback on my hosting style
CU I am trying to um fit with the top 10
Geographics and biographic Brands as
best as I can but I'm by no means a
professional voice actor or indeed
person in front of camera host that's
the word um I was a writer for um sister
site top 10 for many years though and
have like you know experience running my
own YouTube channel either way I hope
everyone enjoyed this subscribe if you
haven't already and as always have the
day you all deserve cheers also just
don't be a to
women